-The January 6th hearings
continue to provide
shocking new revelations
about the degree
to which Donald Trump
and his allies
knew they had no evidence
of election fraud,
knew what they were
doing was illegal,
and still orchestrated
a desperate plan
to overturn the results by,
among other things,
submitting fake electors
and harassing
election officials.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Last week, the committee
revealed the degree to which
Trump's own team
knew their plan to have
Vice President Mike Pence
overturn the election
was illegal
but pushed him to do it anyway.
And now the committee
has revealed
that Trump's team
also admitted, in private,
they had no evidence for their
election-fraud claims, either.
-At some point, did one of them
make a comment that
they didn't have evidence
but they had a lot of theories?
-That was Mr. Giuliani.
-And what exactly did he say,
and how'd that came up?
-My recollection, he said,
"We've got lots of theories.
We just don't have
the evidence."
And I don't know
if that was a gaffe
or maybe he didn't think through
what he said.
-Oh, did Rudy not think
through what he said?
I'm not sure he's ever thought
through anything he's ever said
in his entire life.
In every interview,
he always looks like
he just called someone
the wrong name on a date.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm having a great time
with you tonight, Lisa."
"My name is Deborah."
"I'd say that's
my biggest faux pas,
but I married my cousin."
[ Laughter ]
"Where are you going, Deborah?
I mean, Lisa.
I mean, Deborah?"
[ Laughter ]
Rudy didn't even think through
why the Four Seasons he booked
for a press conference
looked more like a landscaping
company than a hotel.
He just let
the press conference rip.
Like, even if that was
an honest mix-up,
like, what did he think
when he arrived on site?
"This hotel stinks.
You call this a pillow?"
[ Laughter ]
"I do!"
That admission
came in a conversation
with Arizona State House
Speaker Rusty Bowers,
who repeatedly asked
Trump and Rudy
for evidence
of their allegations,
and they repeatedly
failed to provide it.
-During that conversation,
did you ask Mr. Giuliani
for proof of these allegations
of fraud that he was making?
-On multiple occasions, yes.
He said that
they did have proof.
And I asked him,
"Do you have names?"
For example, "We have
200,000 illegal immigrants,"
some large number, "5,000 or
6,000 dead people," et cetera.
And I said,
"Do you have their names?"
"Yes."
"Will you give them to me?"
The President interrupted
and said,
"Give the man what he needs,
Rudy."
He said, "I will."
So Mr. Giuliani was claiming
in the call
that there were hundreds of
thousands of undocumented people
and thousands of dead people
who had purportedly voted
in the election.
-Yes.
-And you asked him
for evidence of that?
-I did.
-And did he ever recei--
did you ever receive
from him that evidence,
either during the call,
after the call, or to this day?
-Never.
-First of all,
I love Trump saying,
"Give the man what he needs."
He really does treat Rudy like
his own personal manservant.
Rudy Giuliani, the man
who supposedly spent his tenure
in New York
taking down the Mafia,
and now he's basically
running errands
like the kid
from "A Bronx Tale,"
hoping to become
a made man someday --
"Right away, boss!"
So, shockingly, Rudy Giuliani
never provided proof
of his claim
that thousands of dead people
voted in the election.
In fact, during one
of these meetings,
Rudy was apparently
so desperate for proof,
he turned to his
fellow pro-coup cronies,
like Trump lawyer Jenna Ellis,
who kept telling Bowers they had
the proof he was looking for.
They just didn't bring it
with them to the meeting.
-At some point,
did Mr. Giuliani ask
one of the other attorneys
on his team
to help him out
with the evidence?
-He did.
He asked Jenna Ellis,
who was sitting to his right.
He did ask,
"Do we have the proof?"
to Jenna, Ms. Ellis,
and she said, "Yes."
And I said, "I want the names.
Do you have the names?"
"Yes."
"Do you have how they voted?"
"We have all the information."
I said, "Can you get to me
that information?"
Did you bring it with you?
She said no.
Both Mr. Giuliani asked her
and I asked generally
if they had brought it
with them.
She said, "No, it's not with me,
but we can get it to you."
-I mean, this is just me,
but if I was preparing
for a high-stakes meeting
with a prominent
Republican official
to convince them to overturn
their state's election results,
reversing the will of
80 million people,
and potentially provoking
a constitutional crisis,
I think I -- and again,
this is just me --
I think I'd remember
to bring the evidence.
[ Laughter ]
Just me. That's just me.
"Oh, man.
The evidence."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, man,
I can't believe I forgot.
In my defense,
I had a terrible night's sleep.
The hotel I stayed at did
not have the best pillows."
[ Laughter ]
They actually thought
they could get away
with saying they had the proof,
just never having it with them.
These people
are such bad scam artists.
It's actually remarkable
how close they came
to overthrowing
American democracy.
In fact, even calling them scam
artists is overstating the case.
That's like calling this guy
a sandwich artist.
At best,
you're a sandwich attempter.
In fact, here's an example
from yesterday
of how bad they are
at being scam artists.
Senator Ron Johnson was trying
to avoid questions
from reporters about a scheme
involving his chief of staff,
who, according to the committee,
tried to hand fake pro-Trump
electors from Wisconsin
and Michigan
to a Pence aide on January 6th.
And when Johnson was approached
by reporters,
he was immediately caught --
immediately caught --
faking a phone call.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone knows
you put the phone
on the same side
as the reporter.
[ Laughter ]
That's scam artistry 101.
So these dip [bleep]
thought they could get away
with convincing
the Arizona State House Speaker
to overturn his state's
election results
by just pretending
they had proof
and would definitely
send it to him
when they got around to it.
They treated a prominent
Republican official
asking for proof
of election fraud
the same way I treated
my dentist's nephew
when he asked for notes
on his screenplay.
"Oh, yeah, man.
You know, I'm --
I'm totally gonna
get those to you.
Just haven't
been home that much."
"You were home
for a full year!"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, damn.
I forgot that was on TV.
Oops. Sorry.
I'm getting a phone call."
[ Laughter ]
[ Mouthing words ]
And yet, despite admitting
in private they had no proof,
Rudy and his gang
still spread wild,
unhinged claims of
election fraud anyway,
like when they targeted
Georgia election worker
Shaye Moss, who testified
at yesterday's hearing,
and her mother,
Ruby Freeman.
Trump and Rudy became obsessed
with an insane conspiracy theory
that somehow involved
Moss and Freeman
tampering with the vote count.
-Tape earlier in the day
of Ruby Freeman
and Shaye Freeman Moss
and one other gentleman
quite obviously, surreptitiously
passing around USB ports
as if they are vials
of heroin or cocaine.
I mean, it's --
it's obvious to anyone
who's a criminal
investigator or prosecutor
they are engaged
in surreptitious,
illegal activity --
again, that day.
And that's a week ago,
and they're still
walking around Georgia.
Why?
Should've been --
they should've been
questioned already.
Their places of work,
their homes should
have been searched
for evidence of ballots,
for evidence of USB ports,
for evidence of voter fraud.
-I mean, this guy really
is out of his [bleep] mind.
I mean, how much --
[ Laughter ]
how much scotch
can one man drink?
I'm starting to think
that wasn't hair dye
leaking out of his head,
it was Johnnie Walker Jet Black.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Rudy ended up
being the one
whose home and office
were searched
for actual evidence of
potential crimes by the FBI.
I'm gonna guess
there was nary a USB port
to be found at Rudy's place.
In fact,
if they found anything,
I bet it was a cigar box
full of old subway tokens
and foul balls he stole from
little kids at Yankee games.
"Give me that, you little runt!
I'm the mayor.
Everybody loves me,
and that's never gonna change."
So you heard Rudy
make the insane claim
that they were passing around
USB ports
at vote-counting sites.
So what were they actually
passing around here?
Here's Shaye Moss's testimony,
which was deeply moving
and powerful
but also contained
this truly insane reveal
about what that
USB port really was.
-Mr. Giuliani accused you
and your mother
of passing some sort of
USB drive to each other.
What was your mom actually
handing you on that video?
-A ginger mint.
-That's right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
A ginger mint.
Of course,
it doesn't surprise me
Rudy wouldn't recognize
a ginger mint.
His breath probably smells like
the inside of a hot-dog cart.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I guess
you can't blame him.
If he was sucking
on a USB drive,
it would probably
still dissolve.
[ Laughter ]
I could definitely see Rudy
confusing a mint
with technology.
"I saw a video of poll workers
passing around
fraudulent ballots.
It was on that
social-media site, Tic Tac.
These guys...
[ Laughter ]
...knew what they were doing
was illegal,
and they knew they had no proof
for their wild, unhinged claims,
but they harassed, bullied,
pressured, and intimidated
people anyway.
And they -- they came
very close to succeeding.
It's very possible
the only thing
that saved our democracy
from total collapse
was the fact that Trump
was surrounded
by absolute morons like Rudy,
whose brain is the size of...
-A ginger mint.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love, We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.